ci sono sei uscite di emergenza su questo
aereo se la cabina dovesse subire
un'improvvisa perdita di pressione la maschera dell'ossigeno
cadrebbe da sopra il sedile Posizionare la
maschera sopra la bocca e il naso in questo modo
nell'improbabile caso di un
atterraggio di emergenza equazione nativa lasciare gli
oggetti a mano  dietro un giubbotto leggero si
trova sotto il sedile avvolgere le cinghie
intorno alla vita unire le due estremità
e stringere il giubbotto può essere
gonfiato manualmente soffiando a un'estremità
dei tubi rossi mentre aspettiamo il
decollo si prega di prendere un momento per rivedere
la sicurezza  scheda dati nella tasca del sedile
di fronte a te